these are running battles between
protesters and the National Guard on
bridges overlooking military bases and
police position they duck for cover then
attacked with stones the guards in full
riot gear respond with volleys of
teargas they try to force the protesters
back
[Music]
from behind you can hear the sound of
advancing motorcycles their guard and
they're firing gas as well
causes pandemonium as they close in the
gas is debilitating people running for
cover
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two gaps in the air like a hard freeze
initially going to go on
[Applause]
was he decided now to move them on
pretty her to it go regroup in a minute
[Applause]
there are thousands of people on the
streets of Caracas looking for guidance
from find Dido and support from the
international community but their
numbers are smaller the violence they
remain determined and believe however
say they need to take the streets people
say rumors abound at senior regime
players want Maduro to go for the
country's poor economy is completely
destroyed by more sanctions it may
happen but for now the regime is still
in charge to Ramsey Sky News correct